well you enjoyed the legal fireworks
last night many pets didn't
in several cases the animals scared and
confused ran off
well if you are looking for your pet
right now there is a chance it could be
at an animal shelter bianca holman
explains what you should do if one
finds their way to your doorstep
[Applause]
red white and blue fireworks across the
valley are a beautiful sight
but these sounds scare dogs and cats
causing them to shake
bark or meow loudly or even run away
we understand what that feels like when
you lose a pet
and i understand what that feels like
it's just sheer
panic and you don't want them to get
hurt you don't know where they are
kelsey peasy at the animal foundation
says this is the busiest time of year
for shelters across the country
for some neighborhoods fireworks
celebrations started early
so the animal foundation has taken in
211 cats and dogs from july
1st to 4th if someone's pet ends up in
your yard
have the vet check for a microchip you
can also post flyers around your
neighborhood
or upload a picture to digital platforms
like facebook and next door
there's also something called petco love
lost which is pretty cool where you can
upload a photo of your pet
they use facial recognition and they
scan all of the local shelters so they
try to make that match as well
since the animal foundation has a foster
program the facility has room to take in
lost
animals the shelter is expecting more
animals throughout the week
if you've done everything you can to try
to find the owner or maybe you can't
keep that lost pet
anymore you can email or call our lost
and found department
and then make an appointment to drop off
that pet and then hopefully we can
reunite that pet with its owner
bianca holman 8 news now now the animal
foundation
is waiving adoption fees for all dogs
and cats all week long this runs through
july 11th you also have the option of
becoming a foster pet parent if you can
do that you can find all that
information right now at 8 newsnow.com